[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
it
is
hump day
happy
[Music]
happy
happy hump day it doesn't feel like hump
day because on monday we had
the holiday memorial day
it doesn't feel like hump day but it is
officially
hump day and you are here with the tony
michaels podcast as you are every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch
and now streaming from the midas touch
facebook page
boy we have a special guest today
we have i i promised you that we would
have this guest
his fi his video kind of went viral he's
over on tick tock and the tick tock made
its way over to
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
i don't know it's got like four or five
six million views something like that
the guy talks about
the issue
of guns and gun safety he knows a thing
or two about gun safety so we're going
to bring that guest in here in just a
minute
i'm very excited to talk to him about
this issue because i think he would know
more than most because of the experience
that he has with these type of weapons
and that is the most important part when
we're having conversations about this
not just to throw around ideas and and
[ __ ] each other and actually hear
from people who actually
have had to make sure that their the
safety is number one and key
with these type of weapons that we're
talking about
that we see that rip through children's
bodies and schools
so how do we make it safe do we lock the
doors
or do we make sure we lock up the guns i
don't know
maybe one two three answers
but we will we will dive into that
i've watched a video yesterday
you see our title of our show is proud
boys cry more
and these [ __ ] in-cell white
nationalists it is really it is really
something there's a couple videos out
there of the proud boys
uh from this nra convention
one where that trump basically told them
to go [ __ ] themselves um you know during
the presidential debate he's like stand
back and stand by now he's like no stand
over there go over there i don't want
you anywhere near me i look like a
traitor when you people are standing
next to me i did that's not a good look
he won't even like cueing on people in
like his entire [ __ ] base his entire
base the proud boys and q and on like
that who who else is there going to vote
for this [ __ ]
who else is going to support this this
clown
besides people who believe in queueing
on
the crazy wackadoo [ __ ] and the proud
boys
he was so proud to have him during the
presidential debate but now
now
now they have their they've been
relegated to a fenced in area outside
the nra convention and whether you know
i i mean six seven of them showed up
a lot of them you know
appeared at this event
and i guess they thought well if we only
bring six or seven of us surely they'll
let us in
sure nope
nope told them to go get [ __ ] and
really it's not about having the people
in right like this has nothing to do
with what type of people they associate
with they really want to associate with
white nationals they really want to
associate with terrorists domestic
terrorist groups like the proud boys and
the oath keepers they just don't want to
appear that way it would be really nice
proud boys if you guys didn't dress up
and do the cosplay proud boy thing
you know put on a different costume is
what he really wants them to do the same
way with the q anon he definitely wants
the q and on crazy
he just doesn't want the costuming
right
he thinks it's gross he thinks they look
trashy he thinks they're not classy
coming from a guy who has gold toilets
by the way have you ever seen pictures
of the inside of this guy's house
you you talk you talk about [ __ ]
trashy holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy is the
epitome
of white class trash
100 full stop
but he just can't handle
you cannot handle the proud boys in
their costumes it's just not a thing
that they're gonna let in
to an event where he's present he
doesn't want to see that type of thing
we you know we got to be sensitive
to the crybaby in chief right
the former guy the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants himself he we really
can't hurt his feelings he has very
sensitive feelings just like the proud
boys
and they're very upset the president the
president says donald trump says we're
supposed to be here
no you can't wear that shirt in here and
that's basically what they're saying in
the video
it's not that they can't be here it's
that you can't wear your costume you
can't wear that shirt in here they don't
want to be associated with domestic
terrorists
is the key
oh lord
well we'll get through that we
definitely are going to
get to this proud boy
issue because there are a couple videos
out there again it's not just the one
where they're telling them to go [ __ ]
themselves
there is that video
where they're like yeah get the hell out
of here not worth it not worth it
but there's a few more videos where
they're standing outside yelling at the
protesters go home and get you a job
that's why you're here because you don't
have a job
while they're there
not having i don't know not having a job
i can't figure that you know this
projection [ __ ]
is their modus operandi
full stop
and it gets worse and worse every single
day like you can see right through them
like this reefer madness you guys have
seen this clip
of laura i'm a nazi ingram on fox news
talking about somehow this shooting was
caused by marijuana are you [ __ ]
serious
this is the same nonsense that that
marijuana is some kind of performance
enhancement drug for the olympics no one
believes that who buys into that anyone
who's ever smoked weed or known someone
who smoked weed
knows
that they're not gonna be motivated to
do anything besides maybe get to the
bottom of the bag of cheetos
you people really are [ __ ] dumb with
this [ __ ]
and and the more we go on where jd vance
wants to ban porn laura ingram wants to
[ __ ] judge you about smoking
marijuana they really are pinning
themselves into a corner here about
their constituency and who's even gonna
[ __ ] take them seriously
they're falling apart all over the place
why do you think they're trying to cheat
in some of these states
because we have news yesterday that
they're trying to cheat in some of these
states they're trying to make it to
where they can change the election if
they want to and of course that's what
they want to do that's what they say the
other side does that's what the
democrats do they just choose who they
want and that's who wins
so that's what they're doing because
that's to projection and it's gonna
continue
the projection that is
like jd vance wanting to ban porn i
don't know maybe he got caught maybe it
got caught lubin and tubin like gabe
says lubin and tubin
someone walked in on him
waxing the old carrot to some porno i
don't know and he's like oh ban all porn
ban all porn we can't handle it
jd you really you really are um giving
away the
giving away the game here with the uh
projection with the porn ban porn
are you [ __ ] kidding porn is the
reason why people are violent
give me a [ __ ] break i'll tell you
what you get a violent person and you
send them in a room with a bunch of porn
and a bunch of marijuana they're
probably not going to be as violent
what the [ __ ] are these white in-cell
trumped-up white dudes going to do if
they don't have porn then we're really
gonna have to probably worry about some
[ __ ] violence
if they ain't got porn and weed to keep
to distract them
jesus christ
i want to welcome all the new listeners
here
to the tony michaels podcast every
single weekday monday through friday the
audience is growing the listeners
are coming in
time after time after time and we
appreciate you being here on youtube
twitter twitch or the midas touch
facebook page boy do you guys love the
chat
and we love having you here on the chat
you guys keep us up to speed sometimes
what happens is is there's breaking news
and we're on the air and we're well i'm
yelling and screaming let's face it i'm
yelling and screaming and i don't see
the news come up on my feed so you guys
warn us in the chat you guys are talking
in the chat working things out in the
chat we have some trolls in the chat
every once in a while so i want to let
all the new listeners know if you want
to go over to the facebook page or the
youtube page
subscribe to the youtube page if you
haven't
but join us in the chat you've got the
super chat over on
youtube the tubes of you if you guys
want to participate in that
also follow us on the twitter page
at tony michael's pod that is super
important because tomorrow as you know
we release the bonehead of the week poll
where we give you the bonehead of the
week and you vote you decide who is the
bone end of the week and on friday in
the second hour because we do two hours
every single day
me and gabe go through the bone end of
the week you you vote we break it down
on friday in the second hour so don't
forget to to
go vote for the bonehead of the week you
can also vote on the youtube page which
is another reason to subscribe to the
youtube page
we also have had a ton of new listeners
on all the podcast directory so you can
download every single episode every
single day monday through friday all two
hours
on google spotify apple all your
favorite directories wherever you
download your podcast you can down there
and the good news is on saturday and
sunday we also have special episodes for
you on saturday we do the best of the
week
and then on sunday we also post the
bonehead of the week
to download on all those directories i
have a special guest for you
today
he goes by
usmc angry vet on twitter an angry
veteran
on the tiki talks he had a video where
he explains to someone on tick tock
like
why the military
actually has protocols and procedures
for i don't know
gun safety
because these weapons may be dangerous
so stick around right after the break we
will bring in matt
united states marine corps angry veteran
right after this break stick around
don't go anywhere we will be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
years
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lib
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
happy to have you here on this
hump day
[Music]
special guest for you today
special special guest he went viral he
went viral matt how are you
i'm doing great how are you guys doing
i'm doing fantastic how does it feel to
be viral now now that you went viral
over on the on on the two i think you've
had several videos before that have that
have gotten a lot of views but the other
day man it just it seemed like it spread
like wildfire because you had a certain
message about these weapons that i think
i think a lot of people understand that
this exists but they don't have the
experience maybe that you have with some
of these weapons being in the military
as long as you were and dealing with
these things tell us about tell us about
the video but more like
what kind of content you're doing
because i think that's important because
you have a different perspective than
maybe some other people when you're
talking about not just liberal issues
and not just gun safety or gun control
but specifically
specifically this issue about these
types of weapons because i keep getting
this in my comments oh it wasn't an ar
you don't know what an ar is you don't
know what this is that isn't that kind
of weapon this is i mean these are all
really dangerous weapons that are
designed to kill human beings am i right
or am i not you're no you're you're
absolutely right uh so
uh a little bit about me uh on uh my
tick tock what i try to do is
bring a different voice to the
conversation uh you don't get a lot of
veterans talking about uh these types of
issues and
you know i uh will always touch on uh
gun violence and how we need to reform
the gun laws and
uh
this time it was just it just felt
different you know i
again
19 children were massacred in their
classroom just trying to
spend the last couple of weeks that they
had in school before going on summer
vacation and
an 18 year old who legally purchased
two guns
uh two ar-15s uh went in and slaughtered
kids
kids and
i
i got angry i mean you know that's the
you know angry vet that's me uh and i'm
angry because
this is
this is our country right now i
you know and this is our country for the
past two decades
uh so i made the video talking about how
i find it very interesting that in the
marine corps
uh not only do you have to re-qualify
with the weapon that you're issued every
single year
if you personally own a firearm that's
one that's not issued to you by the
marine corps one that you personally
went and bought and you are a private
through a sergeant so that's somebody
that's
between the ages of 18 to 21 22 23 years
old and you're living in the barracks
you're not allowed to have that firearm
in your room with you
so my question was
why is it that the marine corps the
finest fighting force in the world the
most heavily trained combat organization
on the planet
does not allow 18 to 21 year olds to
possess
their legally purchased firearms
in their rooms with them and yet an 18
year old who hasn't even graduated high
school yet can just go and buy as many
as he likes store them in his bedroom
and do whatever he wants with it
and that was my question and it's a
question that
i had never heard pose before and
i thought it was a
you know it was just a
poignant and very you know direct way of
saying that if the marine corps
recognizes that
there should probably be some
regulations
on how these weapons are handled and
stored by our service members then maybe
we should also introduce that into the
civilian world
you know
in that in the video because you're
you're talking to someone right so
someone responded to a video where
because i went back and watched a couple
of the tick tocks on your account the
first one you were actually
proposing some actual ideas of what
regulation might look like like right i
mean you were you were giving some
breakdown of some some bullet points
that might fix some of these problems
that we have now now and you i think you
even admit in the video that it's not
going to stop everything and these might
not be the exact solution
but we got to start having this
conversation i think is where you were
going and someone who is also it was in
the united states marine corps they're a
veteran as well they responded to your
video by basically saying you're an
authoritarian and you don't know what
you're talking about and you know you're
a [ __ ] i mean basically saying what
you're saying won't work and what you're
saying is authoritarianism and basically
you were like well if that's
authoritarianism then you lived an
authoritarianism rule
under the united states marine corps now
to be fair
the military is different than civilian
life completely different 100 percent it
is different
but the weapons
the weapons seem to be
very similar
because i get this all the time you lib
[ __ ] you [ __ ] lib you don't know
anything about guns well i grew up in
rural america we had guns in my house we
went deer hunting i shot many guns i i i
was never really into guns
i was into other things like drinking
beer and running around
you know doing things i probably
shouldn't have been doing
but the the thing is that i i we never
had pistols um in our house we never had
assault rifles because our guns we
didn't view them as
bad guys were going to come get us we
didn't have the [ __ ] enemies that
these people apparently have like that's
why you have these weapons because the
military
in essence has quote unquote enemies
right you guys a lot of times are
fighting in active combat that's why you
have to have these types of weapons so
tell us tell us about
if you can because i know you have way
more expertise than i would have on this
issue because i just don't have the
experience with these type of weapons
that you do tell us about
why
the gun that are that are used in some
of these recent mass shootings in
buffalo uvalde even all the way back to
sandy hook why are these the same type
of weapons and what what if there is
anything that makes them different tell
me what makes these different from the
weapons that we would use in war
sure so i'll start with what makes them
different
uh the ar-15
uh which stands for armalite rifle and
it's the 15th model or whatever
um
the only difference between that and an
m16 that you would get issued through
the marine corsair
is that the m16 has a third fire setting
which is basically a three-round burst
so there there are no automatic m16s uh
in the marine corps
uh basically you have safety you have
you know safe you have single fire
semi-automatic uh rate of fire and then
you have a three round burst
on the civilian side of things it's
exactly the same except for that you do
not have the three round burst option
so that is literally the only difference
uh the rate of fire is exactly the same
the velocity you know the max effective
range the magazines that go into the
ar-15 are the exact same ones that we
would put into an m16 so you can put up
to 30 rounds in those magazines at a
time and you can carry six or seven of
them
very easily they're not heavy
uh so i think when we get to why are
these the go-to guns for these mass
shootings it's simply because you are
able to put more rounds through the
rifle
uh than you are through say like a
pistol uh or you know a shotgun
you're able to fire off more rounds on
top of that
the regulations and the controls for an
for a long rifle like that are far less
stringent than those are for a handgun
in the state of new york where i'm from
where i live uh you have to get a
specific permit to even
go into a
uh gun store in the state and even have
them open the case to let you hold one
of them whereas a
rifle
we don't have those uh those
restrictions um
and so honestly when it comes to why are
these the go-to weapons of choice ease
of access and rate of fire
so so what you're saying is that
because these weapons are designed
for
max
um damage on a human being because
that sounds like what they're designed
for i don't think they designed an m16
to go deer hunting with they absolutely
did not right i mean i would think that
if you would need that then maybe you
should probably practice more at the
range or pick up a different hobby i
don't know yeah right or stop trying to
hunt rambo deer right well yeah right
you know when when i was a kid that the
rifle that we used for deer hunting had
a clip that held six rounds and really
honestly we wouldn't even put six rounds
in because my dad was like if you need
more than two or three you don't need to
be hunting deer like these deer are not
heavily armed right exactly like they're
not heavily armed they're not wearing
black jackets most of them well i don't
know maybe moe brooks is dear that's
true
well but but
the best defense they have is to run
right
from a rifle that contains a clip that
is
a lesser amount of rounds than i don't
know
a gazillion because it seems like
and the more information that we have
that this
this 18 year old that bought these guns
in uvalde
um in this situation specifically it
doesn't even seem like he paid for the
guns like we're in a situation where
this this 18 year old on his birthday
went into a store bought two rifles
bought 17 rounds on a credit card and
i'm not sure the exact situation here we
need to wait to see but it seems like
that is what happened because so he did
not even purchase these weapons he just
went in and used a piece of plastic to
get to possess these weapons so that he
could he could
create the maximum amount of damage
now speaking of damage because i think
that's the other thing that is the
fallacy here about these rifles
uh versus like a handgun like you were
talking about
is that these rifles
are designed
to destroy flesh
right it's not it's not designed to go
in one side of you and out the other
side right it is designed to create
maximum amount of damage because when
you're in a combat situation and you
have a real enemy not third graders who
are unarmed hiding underneath desk that
are terrified for their lives or a
teacher who stands in front of a group
of students and takes bullets in their
back so that they die instead of the
students it's not what we're talking
about here we're talking about in a
combat situation is there is someone who
is wearing body armor who has the same
type of armory that you may have an
assault style rifle a weapon designed
for war to kill and do his maximum
amount of damage so when you are in that
situation
to save your life sometimes
you have to have a weapon that is act
that is appropriate enough in that
situation in war we're talking about
real combat and real war which they
train the united states marine corps to
be in that's why they have those weapons
so i guess my question is
tell us about the difference because you
have you've used these weapons on the
firing range you you've seen them you've
held them you've shot them i have two
but you have way more experience because
you've had to actually train every
single year to recertify for this
tell us about the type of damage because
i think that's one thing that this
country is doing is not realizing these
weapons you know they're saying oh you
can buy them they're different than a
handgun it's the same as this rifle it's
the same as that rifle
but actually tell us what this would do
if you were in close range of another
human being because i think people are
that's lost on people that that is
actually what is happening it you know
they want to blame it on oh it's the guy
it's the mental illness when you're
standing in a classroom a couple feet
away from another human being and you're
using one of these rifles it's about the
amount of damage that it can do you know
they say all knives and bats and ball
bats and all that [ __ ] give me a [ __ ]
break you're not understanding the
amount of damage that these rifles
actually do to a human being so tell us
what your experience is on actually
firing these weapons and what kind of
damage they can actually do to another
human in close range
sure uh so when it comes to firing an
ar-15 or an m16
uh
they're relatively easy to shoot there's
not a lot of recoil to it it's not like
you're you know firing off a
buckshot you know
double barrel shotgun so
you know they're pretty comfortable to
shoot
um
you
know sorry um
i think would you want to talk about the
damage
that these types of weapons can do
we've already seen
um
out of uvaldi the type of damage that
these weapons can do at close quarters
parents had to get their cheeks swabbed
to test the dna of the body so that the
bodies could be identified
if you want to talk about the type of
damage that these weapons can do and
more specifically it's the type of ammo
that is used in these weapons
um
they eviscerate
people
the ammo that we used in the marine
corps it's a nato 556 round
it is designed that when it enters the
body it breaks apart
so that you don't have a small exit
wound you cause the most damage
internally as you possibly can
that's firing into a grown person who is
shooting back at you right your your
purpose with that is to cause the most
damage to get yourself out of that
situation out of that dangerous
situation as you can so when you're in
close quarters and you're firing at
children
i don't think there's any better imagery
to describe the type of damage that can
be done than the thought of a mother
having to swab the inside of her cheek
to identify their child
i know it's a difficult thing to talk
about and
it's
but i think we can't look away from this
you're absolutely right that's really
that's really i think what we're missing
in this whole debate
um
is the imagery that you're giving
because it is super important that we
understand that it's it's
this this back banning back doors and
turning schools into prisons and
um all this stuff because
frankly
what's stopping what's stopping a person
waiting for the bell to strike three
o'clock these kids come out in a crowd
outside that one door because ted cruz
says huh one door
so they know they're gonna come out that
one door and they're not they're not
just one of them
all of them are coming out that one door
so i mean if you're gonna talk about
safety and security i i believe that
that is a fallacy in and of itself
because
of these type of weapons and what they
can do and what they're designed to do
they're designed to
to eviscerate flesh like you said and
to to
to the point
that the cops in uvalde the police
department and some of these tactical
teams
didn't even want to go into that
building
and to their
not my words their words they were
scared to be shot and the reason why
they're scared to be shot folks is
because the ammo and the weapon that he
had would tear off their limbs
that's why the police officers were like
well
do i risk my life going in there
this is the reason why
the entire country should look to greg
abbott and say
why did you do this to the uvalde police
put them in a position to do this
because this 18 year old did not have to
get this gun he did not have to get
those guns that day that much ammo that
is all bogus that's all [ __ ] that's
not has anything to do with anyone's
second amendment right it's all
nonsense it's drivel and it's only it's
only to protect a handful of families
ability to make profit on their
their patents which are weapons of war
and that and that is the bare simple
facts you can beat around the bush all
you want and because because of that i
want to play your video here
because you absolutely do not beat
around the bush
with this video in your response to the
other marine corps veteran
um i forget her name offhand here but
you were responding to her video in this
video where she basically said you're
full of [ __ ] you know you don't know
what you're talking about and then you
explain how you actually
know what you're talking about so let's
watch the video here hi
i'm glad that you said that you were a
marine corps veteran because i wanted to
bring this point up how many times a
year do you have to go as a marine to
re-qualify and prove that you are
competent and proficient in the weapons
that you have been issued
i'll answer that for you as a former
rifle pistol coach in the marine corps
you have to go annually
and how long does that take two weeks
right you have a week of grass week and
then a week of live fire isn't that
right so in the marine corps you have to
go for two weeks out of your life and
prove to the marine corps that you are
still proficient in the weapons that
have been issued to you now let's take
it a step further let's say you're a
private through a sergeant that's living
in the barracks in the marine corps are
you allowed to store a firearm in your
barracks room the answer is no you are
not if you privately own a weapon you
have to go and register that weapon with
the provost marshal's office and then
they issue a receipt to you saying where
your weapon will be stored and kept safe
for you why is it that the united states
marine corps the finest fighting force
on the planet
is more restrictive and who and where
firearms can be stored and possessed
than the average 18 year old in the
state of texas
why you see your plan is to just do
nothing and ignore the problem and
continue to pray and hope that it goes
away well guess what erica that's not
[ __ ] working
okay that is not [ __ ] working
let's look at the second amendment for a
second all right the second amendment
says a well-regulated
militia if you believe that the second
amendment applies to all citizens and
all citizens are supposed to be that
militia what do you think well
regulated means
it doesn't mean
no regulations
jesus christ why is this so [ __ ] hard
to understand
doing
nothing
makes it easier for children to get
slaughtered in their schools
[ __ ] all the way off
i think you um you put it very well
there and the rest the rest of parents
in america who have children in schools
that that
even now um
yeah some parents the children's are out
of schools and they're they're relieved
almost that hey i don't have to worry
about taking them to this building where
they may be slaughtered but we still
worry about the grocery store and our
church um you know
and and it's because of some of these
issues that you bring up a couple things
i want to ask you about the video
because i had a couple questions
um about the two weeks that uh when
you're in the marine corps that you have
to go recertify i forget the actual name
that you call it um where you're
recertifying to basically prove to them
that you're proficient in this weapon
you said there's two weeks there's grass
week and there's something else explain
those two weeks to us give us a little
deeper dive into what does that look
like like when you're actually training
for these weapons what do you do in
those two weeks sure
uh so the first week is called uh grass
week in the marine corps and again i've
been out of the marine corps for about
11 years so they may have changed a few
things since i've been in it may not be
a full two weeks anymore for
recertifying and bring quality
uh but when i was in you would go for
two weeks the first week was grass week
where it was dry fire so you had your
weapon you had your sling and you
practiced getting into the shooting
positions uh um practicing your proper
sight alignment your proper trigger
discipline
uh and you would basically sit in kind
of a semi-circle around a barrel in the
middle which had paintings of the
targets that you would be shooting at
during live fire week um
and you spend
six to seven hours a day just
practicing in those positions getting
your body used to you know your sitting
position your kneeling position your
standing position your prone position
and getting back into that uh into those
uh
positions i said that a lot um
and then uh
once you're done with that then you go
into live fire week which is
uh you have a week of
uh you have
four days no i'm sorry yeah no you have
four days of uh
live fire week and then a day of
qualification and you will practice uh
shooting from the two three and five
hundred yard lines in those various
different shooting positions and you
have to score a certain amount of points
on the target to qualify as either a
marksman or sharpshooter or an expert if
you don't then you have to go back for
recall
uh on the fifth day uh or the week after
um and if you don't qualify again
then there could be you know
administrative action taken against you
uh maybe they make you do it a third
time if you're in boot camp uh and you
don't qualify after that second time
they then you get recycled through you
do the whole thing all over again if you
don't qualify that time then they kick
you out
so you have to constantly be proving to
the marine corps every single gear that
you're proficient uh with not only the
firing procedures uh and the handling of
that weapon but the safety procedures to
make sure that nothing um adverse
happens while on the range
so keeping good muzzle discipline
trigger discipline like i talked about
you know being aware that there are live
rounds on the range and that you know
you have coaches like i would that on
the range would go and make sure that
before you got off of the firing line
and moved back towards where everybody
else was that your weapon was clear
there was no live round in it
that way
you
dramatically reduce the uh
the probability of an adverse event
happening on the range if something does
happen on the range you flag the firing
line with your muzzle whether there's a
round in it or not
uh you know
you could get kicked off the range for
the day because you violated the safety
of the range
so it's very restrictive in you know
what you're shooting when you're
shooting and how you're shooting it's
also very restrictive in the way that
you're handling the weapon even when
there isn't a round in the chamber
it sounds like to me
that
these these are reasonable actions for
such a dangerous weapon and
i don't have the video queued up but you
did um
the video here that we just watched it
was in response to a response of another
video and i know that seems weird but on
tick tock as opposed to in a thread on
twitter where you're back and forth um
it's kind of like a they call it a
stitch i think or a reply and you're
actually just you're you're replying to
them from one video to the next so it's
kind of like a thread of videos right um
for anyone who's not on tick-tock or not
familiar with tick-tock but you had made
a video where you had actually suggested
some of these gun safety
common sense regulations that might be
common sense
some of them seemed uh reasonable some
of them seem to go further than what i
would even consider to be reasonable and
i don't i don't think you were trying to
be unreasonable i think you were just
saying hey
these are things that could change the
game right regardless of if they would
go into effect or not because i i think
you're pro-democracy
um and and and what i mean by that is
that you seem to have a sense that hey
we're not going to get everything we
want and and that's kind of what your
video said but doing nothing is not
doing anything right right we're not
we're not doing the main thing which is
protecting our citizens from each other
like we're not protecting each other
from each other we're not doing that
simple act in our democracy and we can
do that now we we're not going to be
perfect right like you're saying
i'm sure there was instances even on the
fire range as safe as it was as well
trained as all those people where there
may have been some instances that could
have hurt someone or someone may have
gotten hurt so it's not perfect because
these [ __ ] weapons
are dangerous they're they're dangerous
that's the idea that's why the marine
corps makes you re-certify because they
want to make sure you're not a danger to
any other service member right like it's
not i mean
they have to worry about you being a
danger to yourself they have to worry
about you being in danger on the
battlefield but in these controlled
environments where there are other
service members they don't want you
being doing dangerous things around the
other the other service members like
handling your weapon cleaning the gun
making sure there's you know like you
said what rounds are what rounds are
when they're loaded when they're not how
you handle the gun
the positions that you're in all that is
in i mean
yes it's for war and training but that's
partially to keep your other service
members
safe right
um
so how do we
because i i know you had a few
suggestions in the first video that you
made that was a response to the response
of the video we just watched that kind
of went viral but what do you think we
can do what are some reasonable common
sense things that we can take maybe
modeled after some of the things they do
in the service and apply it to our
citizenry so we're not we're not
endangering each other just because
we got gun boners right because that
seems like what this is is i got a boner
for guns so i don't want
you to tell me what i can and can't do
and the sacrifice is that 19
children in the school can get
slaughtered that's just the sacrifice we
have to make i don't think that's a
sacrifice we have to make what do you
think are some of them reasonable common
sense things that we can do to make sure
gun safety um is applied to is applied
everywhere
and can keep citizens safe
from these firearms
uh i know a couple of things that i had
talked about uh
in the original video was before you
even go into a gun store to purchase a
firearm
there being three different permits that
you have to that you have to have the
first being a permit showing that you
have sat through an eight-hour safety
course on the weapon that you want to
purchase
the second is a permit showing that you
have gone to a live fire range and
proved that you not only are proficient
but safe with the weapon that you have
and the third permit would be a
uh
promise more or less that you will make
sure that that weapon is stored uh and
maintained properly so if your weapon
does show up in a crime you're held
liable for it
i feel like those three things right
there they're not you know those three
things are not out of outside of the
realm of
you know
infringing on your right to own a
firearm it's literally just saying show
us that you will be responsible with it
right that's that's really what it is uh
i go into in that video talking about uh
expanding the background searches and
the background checks
for people that want to purchase
firearms uh
now in my video i said you know for
every firearm
it could be you know if you want to
purchase an ar-15 you have a more
extensive background check than somebody
that wants to buy a hunting you know
rifle or a shotgun you know it doesn't
like i said in the video the proposals
that i put into that video were not
perfect but they were something uh so
you know more in-depth intensive
background searches for on people to
ensure that
you know i know a lot of states do not
have their criminal background searches
will not check and see if you have any
kind of protective order against you if
you've had any kind of domestic violence
charges brought against you they won't
check your social media to see if you
have made threats towards people uh you
know they won't go into these things
they won't look into you know your
mental health status have you been
involuntarily
committed to an inpatient you know
hospital because of a mental health
break these are all things that you know
if we just implement we could start to
see
these types of situations where people
are so
easily able to obtain these weapons
probably aren't going to be able to do
it but it has to be something from the
federal level because not all states are
going to do that we've seen that in
texas texas is not going to do that
texas is going to make it as easy as
possible
governor abbott went out and complained
that more guns were being sold in
california than in texas and that texas
needed to pick it up
and that's a problem that's a problem
okay your whole identity of your state
should not focus around a firearm right
you should be proud of your state for
other reasons maybe letting your
elementary school kids get out of
elementary school would be something to
be proud of in this country
but
if we continue to just
turn the argument away from any kind of
solution a lot of people are arguing
with me now about you know the
definition of the term well regulated at
the time that the constitution was
written and how you know the supreme
court has constantly upheld that you
know owning firearms is available to i'm
like i don't care i don't care if we're
going to argue semantics then we might
as well just stop talking about this
until the next group of children are
slaughtered in their school right
because
you're you're just trying to shift the
focus away from solutions and
draw people into this idea that you
don't care right your guns are more
important than children
so
i think keeping people focused keeping
people on topic and not allowing
ourselves to get drawn off of course is
just as important as the proposals that
are put forward
you know i think you well yeah i was
gonna say i think you make some some
excellent points and i think those are
not outrageous right like whether you
want to talk about a well-regulated
militia right let's look at the
industries that are actually safe and
regulated because there's an oversight
to them right as opposed to just saying
willy-nilly anyone can do whatever they
want we've clearly seen the downsides
and the collateral damage to when
someone can do whatever they want
whether it's the financial district or
it's it's the gun industry but i think
you know even if you want to get your
car i think it actually might be more
requirements than we got when we got our
license i think now it's like 50 hours
of training 10 hours at night six hours
with an instructor like you have to take
a written test you have to take the
driving test and that's just to drive a
car right now
gabe that's because a vehicle is a very
dangerous thing right of course that's a
very it's a two-ton weapon
that's a battering ram of course it's
dangerous but when you have a weapon
that basically
annihilates and pulls apart human flesh
that's not a problem clearly but i mean
you know it's to say when people go
oh well you can't you can't make me
register the gun you can't do this it's
like you know it's the same argument
people were like well you know masks
don't do anything it's like well you
know
seat belts work they're effective when
driving they're not a hundred percent
but they'll get you most of the way
there to make sure that you don't go
flying to the windshield and the same
way when we look at guns it's like maybe
we should take a step back and figure
out how we should actually deter this
type of
this this uh this damage from happening
in the future and maybe we should offer
you know a permitting process or
training or licensing again
not
radical ideas they're just ideas that
ensure the safety and the well-being of
those in your community that way we
don't have to send our kids to school
thinking
i don't know if they'll come back today
right which is an unfortunate and
ridiculous thing
that we have in the year 2022. yeah no
and i uh you know
i recognize that
this is a multi-faceted issue here right
in the state of new york or at least in
my
kids school district there is a whole
process that you have to go through the
doors are the doors are locked here you
know there's a you know a raptor
program i don't even know what this is
but you put your uh
your driver's license into it and it
kind of scans to see if there's anything
before they even let you walk into the
school
so i mean it's not you know this isn't a
you know we should ignore this problem
and focus on this problem it has to be a
multi-faceted solution
and i'm not saying that schools should
just be open to anybody that wants to
walk in i don't know anybody that's
saying that
but
that can't also be the only focus right
we can't because like like you said tony
you know
these shootings these massacres aren't
just happening at schools
buffalo it happened at a supermarket so
do we have to also fortify supermarkets
you know churches in california you know
the there was the massacre at the church
there uh do we also have to fortify
churches like where where does it stop
this everywhere that we go have to be
prison level of fortification and entry
and exit procedures or can we focus on a
broader issue and just make it harder
for people to get a hold of the weapons
that are causing this destruction
well you know
some that that is great points and
you know it kind of goes to multifaceted
because
jd vance in ohio is blaming it on porn
um
ted cruz wants to blame it on
uh backdoors ron johnson wants to blame
it on morals and faith now i believe
that there is a cultural aspect to this
right
there is this um
part of
and and i'm just gonna say it i don't
give a [ __ ] white privileged society
that believes it's the same it's the
same group of people who believed they
could spread around covid because it was
their right to spread around kovid it's
the same thing as i get to do whatever i
want whenever i want because i'm part of
the privileged society and this is
america and it's my freedom
to knock on your freedom and you have to
like it right it's this culture and i
believe that the people who are yelling
and screaming about the culture are the
worst part of this gun culture that we
have
and i just don't understand how um they
can't see their projection into this
conversation but i believe there is a
good conversation to have about culture
you know if they want to have it um it
definitely has nothing to do with naked
people having sex on screen and it
definitely has nothing to do with back
doors i don't know tony i've seen some
porns and i really got
i was like oh i gotta let this
frustration out and then i mean no
backdoor type porn boy it really i know
it's like who came in you know i don't
know who you know it's a whole thing i
didn't have a screening process involved
in that you know but it it it is so
infuriating like yesterday we watched a
video of kurt cameron that went around
social media yesterday where he was
talking about well we had to home school
kids and that's the problem and it's
like i really i mean you can homeschool
your children and you have the freedom
to do that in this country because we do
have rights and i can't oppress your
rights because you want to homeschool
your children but the last people that i
want to be indoctrinating their children
into their ideals and their ideology are
these people who clearly want violence
um because
i think you
ran into it almost
but i think when you talk about grocery
stores being fortified churches being
fortified concerts
they really the gun manufacturers in the
republican party the fascists in this
country
because of a handful of people who
actually manufacture there's a handful
of families that manufacture weapons in
this country it's not like there's
hundreds and thousands of manufacturers
that's not the case
there are a handful of
manufacturers in this country who are
making
just mountains of money
off the slaughter of our citizens
because
they want us to do that
i think this teacher talk where they
want to arm the teachers is ridiculous
as it sounds they don't find it
ridiculous matt that means profit that
means every every classroom there's a
gun that's goods for sales baby the
other thing too is in churches and in
grocery stores jesus carry carry your
semi-automatic rifle into the subway to
order a foot long
look this is good for business if
everyone has to carry a gun
everywhere when it's the wild west
and the main the main product to be sold
is gun and gun accessories these gun
manufacturers are super
super [ __ ] excited about this
and i think
that is being lost in the culture talk
that we
really do have this problem in the
country with a gun style culture not not
a freedom style culture right like a
freedom style culture culture you do not
have to go to subway and worry about
someone gunning you down so you have to
carry a firearm that's not freedom that
is not freedom that's not how it works
like the freedom to enter the subway
get your sandwich
be safe exit
eat your sandwich
go on home or go to the movie whatever
the hell you're gonna do that's the
freedom that's why
people
were saying you should wear a mask so
you don't get people sick inside the
subway right like it wasn't about
restricting your freedom it was about
allowing other people to go in and get
that sandwich and had the freedom to eat
that sandwich without having to get sick
just like without having to get shot
without having to protect themselves
with a goddamn firearm it really is this
culture where
they have totally turned freedom on its
head um they that this white privilege
gun i can do anything i want type
culture so i think we need to have that
conversation that is definitely a
conversation we need to have but jd
vance it's it's it's not about porn well
you guys bring up interesting point
right like matt you bring up like are we
just going to fortify all these places
you know and and tony says well it's
great it's great for business and if you
look at the actual you know where the
money comes from right like you've got
trump during the presidency private
prison industry actually was
doing one of its greatest kind of tours
in terms of ice detention centers uh
other places in which they could hold
people it was the deals that were
contingent on the fact of allowing
people to be imprisoned under the trump
administration you know especially these
are people who are private prison donors
the actual people who run these prisons
are the ones who are contributing to
trump's uh campaign
and so you look at this and you say well
this this is weird you guys want one
door and you want fencing and high walls
and security and scanning
it's literally a prison you guys are
describing a prison as your solution
it's not the guns
it's it's we want to build a prison
and you look at that and you say as
messed up and twisted as it is
it kind of makes sense why you want that
right you don't want to get away from
that you don't want to get rid of the
gun you want to just create so that the
guns have more rights and are more
actually more free outside this you know
whatever the building is
than you are inside the building or
outside
and it's it's insane to look at kind of
how people will or republicans will
value
those things right and how they will
again anything under the sun we've got
laura ingraham who's talking about
reefer madness or i think she called it
uh pot uh psychosis right yeah um scary
stuff yeah scary scary stuff you know i
got here look i got my weed right here
like i might you know i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna and some people won't be like
oh it's cannabis marijuana okay whatever
anyway the point is i've got over here
and i have never once smoked
and then said
i'm gonna go purchase a gun
and i'm gonna go commit this crime that
has never i've more more often than not
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm so tired now or
like i don't want to leave my house or i
want to order grubhub or whatever it is
right these twinkies taste really good
yeah i don't even like twinkies and i'm
willing to eat the twinkies after the
fact he would eat taco bell and he would
not ever eat taco bell but it's just one
of those things where you look at it and
they'll be like yeah we want to we want
to give more rights and protection of
the building itself
not the people that are in it right and
not actually look at well let's look
this is a systemic problem let's
actually trace it back now we're just
putting band-aids on something and
really in tech there's something else do
i want to point out is in tech you can
either solve a problem with software
like code or you can solve a problem
with people right and you look at that
and you're like well i can solve this
people by throwing more bodies on it
right which costs more money and
essentially what republicans are doing
right now is they're throwing people
onto a problem they're trying to solve
it by saying more people will actually
fix it because there's more surveillance
yet you know in places like uvalde and
other places in texas and other states
we actually don't have enough people
according to what they're telling us so
that's why more people might be rampant
and that's why we need to give teachers
more guns which is ridiculous you know
uh and in this solution it's actually
well how do we solve this without more
people right how do we make it the
cheapest most effective way to solve a
problem and that's actually to go back
and say we need to issue these three
types of permits that you need to access
training hours you know actual uh
teaching
um as opposed to well more guards more
teachers and whatever and i think the
last point too is
in parkland sandy hook we have uh
marshalls is what their teachers are
called they're you know they're anointed
kind of martial uh programs where
they're given guns
some teachers go through the program
like i don't want to do this but in
states like florida and texas this has
already been in place since 2013 right
and in 2018 and they have done studies
have shown again
and again and again that they literally
do not prevent anything or stop it even
if in its tracks so let me ask you man i
want to have a conversation back and
forth so gabe leave it on the screen
because i want to talk to you because
you probably have some experience in
actually securing buildings right um
i mean in in your in your combat in in
some of your training you probably have
a lot of training in securing a building
meaning sure you know making sure that
no one enters exits and you're you're
armed you're there to prevent them from
coming in and out and we saw some videos
from uvalde
where
the police were preventing the parents
to come in now it's unclear at this
point what the timing was the ivaldi
police are really on the hot seat here
it seems like something went on that
they're not trying to they're trying to
hide from us um but nevertheless in a
situation where you would arm a building
right right you would because that's
their solution is armed guards right
more guns are the teachers have but in
your experience in guarding a building
like
what what does it mean
do these morons when they suggest these
ideas do they actually understand like
what do you do when you're guarding a
building like what's the main key what's
the main key when you're guarding a
building
so
when you're guarding if you're guarding
in a way that you want to prevent
something from happening controlling the
entry and exit points are obviously
uh crucial you want to make sure that
the people coming in and out are the
people that you want coming in and out
uh scanning people you know ensuring
that they're not bringing things in that
they're not supposed to be bringing in
um
constant patrols around the building to
ensure that
nobody's trying to sneak in
um
and i think it you know something that
also gets kind of lost in this whole
conversation is if you put
more guns into an active shooter
situation right so somebody breaks into
a school and they've got
you know or in a supermarket or whatever
and they've got a gun and they're
starting to shoot on people and the
police make entry and there are 10 or 15
other people that also have guns how do
the police know which one is the bad guy
and which one is the good guy
so if somebody turns a corner real quick
with a pistol trying to hunt down the
actual active shooter and runs into the
police what is the guarantee that that
person trying to do the right thing
isn't also going to get shot like there
isn't any there is no guarantee to that
so you got to remember that in these
situations it's hectic it's chaotic
there's a lot of unknowns it's scary
your adrenaline is russian your fine
motor skills kind of go out the door for
this higher level awareness
that you know
kind of dictates your actions the whole
way through so
i actually brought up a point uh because
you were talking about the more more
people aspect of things um
there's a lot of people talking we just
need more guns more guns we'll solve
this problem and my question is there
are 400 million guns in the united
states right now at what point does that
number hit a tipping point to where
we're actually safe
because 400 million isn't that number so
how many more do we need you know so
when you're talking about securing a
building and whatnot it's easier to
secure a building with less
distractions than there are with more
and i feel if you add more weapons into
the situation it just creates more
distractions
you know the funny part about the the
securing of building you know prisons
all around the country and i brought
this up the other day
there's no guns especially past a
certain point inside of a prison so like
if your your idea is to turn
a schoolhouse into a prison
it would not be a good idea to institute
guns peppered in every single room
throughout that prison like that's not a
good idea because this whole good guy
bad guy thing that's a fallacy too and i
brought this up yesterday that you get a
teacher who thinks they're a good guy
with a gun right and thinks that an uh a
teacher down in the cafeteria who's
unarmed is the bad guy well the good guy
turns into a bad guy really quick inside
that cafeteria with children and that
bad guy teacher as the good guy with the
gun season it's really stupid like this
fallacy good guy bad guy and i think
that's one thing that this the facts
that the
that the evaldi shooting is really
bearing out is that most americans are
going maybe this good guy should
all all [ __ ] like maybe that's all
[ __ ] you know they bought into it
because i was talking to someone the
other day about um gun reform and they
were they were spewing facts and they
were taking picking apart little things
um and they're for gun reform like this
person i was talking to and i said i
told them eventually i said look
we are on the same page
you want you want reasonable gun reform
i want reasonable gun reform i said the
problem is
is that
you believe you're on the side of the
gun manufacturers
and you're not
they have convinced you with these these
arguments that you're making and they're
using your arguments the good guy with
the gun the oh there's not as many
deaths with guns as there are with cars
and there's more this and there's more
that these little tidbit things that
they use
to make people feel warm and fuzzy about
their gun that they own right
i said there the gun manufacturers are
using those arguments in their quest to
do the things that you don't want them
to do
they're using your arguments your
reasonable arguments about weapons that
yes there are there are reasonable
people who own these weapons there can
be responsible gun owners i don't think
we actually have to get rid of and melt
down every ar-15 in this country but we
need to make it very difficult and you
have to prove your responsibility for
these guns you have to prove your
responsibility to society to the rest of
us that you're responsible enough and he
agreed but i said the arguments that
you're making is the arguments that the
gun lobby the republicans who do want to
do the opposite of what you want to do
are using i said so stop using those
arguments
start being on the side of safety not on
the side of the gun manufacturers
because i think that's part of the
problem that we have right with the
conversation is 90 of people are for
background checks and everyone's like
how the hell do we not have this done
the reason why is because
the people who are for background checks
the arguments that they're making about
why they want to keep their gun right
why they want to have the ability to buy
a gun are the arguments that are being
used against the background check so
fair to have those arguments you're free
to have those arguments
but don't let the gun lobby don't let
the republicans don't want the people
who want to do the opposite of what you
believe is reasonable
use your arguments
against the things that you want you're
doing that so until we get people
who are second amendment people who who
want guns who want to own guns who want
people to own guns until they come to
the table and admit that i am against
these things and i am against the gun
manufacturer using these arguments
against the american people to have
common sense [ __ ] like like you said you
you know these three things that you
mentioned earlier that does not seem out
of the realm of someone who would really
want to purchase these type of firearms
that they could do it doesn't seem that
out of torque right
those simple little things that we can
do to prevent some of this and to try to
keep the citizenry safe
the arguments that are being used
are the people who want to have those
things their arguments are being used
against those things and i think until
we get to that point past this because
it is part of culture like we were
talking earlier get past this culture
part and get over this hump and i don't
know how many um
dead elementary school students have to
die before we actually look at each
other and go you know let's stop using
these arguments um
to keep this slaughter going let's
actually use these arguments to actually
do something and to tell these
politicians in the nra to [ __ ] off you
can take and the gun manufacturers go
sell guns to the military
sell you're not going to be able to sell
these guns anymore you're just not going
to be able to do it well especially
especially the guns that the politicians
use in their ads whether it's margery
taylor green or brian kemp or whoever it
is they're using those guns to normalize
this culture that is well if i've got a
problem the way to solve that problem or
potentially get rid of someone is with
the gun right i gotta shoot this
huge ass caliber rifle from afar in a
truck to explode a car like
that's not practical whether you're
trying to use that as some sort of like
uh
you know symbolism or whatever
it doesn't it's not necessary you can
you could get around you could be more
effective with another approach and one
that isn't so destructive and violent
but
you know
well try to get marjorie taylor green to
be reasonable that good luck
she's also the one that had uh she's
also gonna have that facebook uh
it was a it was a raffle right right
right gave away a rifle which is like
hey when i where i come from gabe and
rule and rule uh america they would give
they would give rifles away if you open
up a new savings account you've seen
that in bowling for columbine and the
mike
you they would give raffles away at the
school ffa they would have a raffle to
raise money and they would give away at
the high school they would give away a
rifle um in a raffle so matt i really
appreciate you joining us but before we
go
i want you to tell everyone where they
can find you because i know you have you
have a big tick tock following over
there for people to find you on ticket
but also tell everyone where they can
find you and also i i think you have
some causes that you support so i want
to give you a minute to do some
shameless uh plugging here so go ahead
go ahead and give us your shameless plug
here perfect yeah so you can find me on
tick tock at usmc angry veteran on
twitter at usmc angry vet
and i have
recently started not recently but
i work with a organization called common
defense which is a collective of
progressive veterans across the country
who push a lot of uh
lobbying to our elected officials for
things like uh you know common sense gun
reform and voting rights access and
bodily autonomy
a woman's right to choose things like
that we've got 300 000 members in that
organization so that was very uh that
that's been a great organization i also
do some work and we'll start doing more
work with moms on demand and every town
and march for our lives as well to help
continue to push this uh
push this radical idea that maybe we
need to do something to stop children
from dying in their schools
well i i really do i really do
appreciate you stopping by and giving us
all your knowledge and and as much time
as you've given us uh thank you very
much always come back please come back
soon
and talk about this i know i know
there's supposed to be a big uh you
mentioned march for our lives um and
mom's on demand i think there's supposed
to be a big rally in dc on the 11th of
this month so it's coming up very
quickly uh it's quick planning but i
think it's a good action to take to show
the rest of the country that hey if you
are for common sense
gun safety you're not alone like we have
to show them we have to show them so
thank you for joining us i appreciate
you all yes yeah hey no problem
anytime you have something you want to
say or if you have a viral tick tock
video that you want to talk about
you know you just just come on back
anytime you are welcome here at the tony
michaels podcast thank you matt everyone
stick around we will be right back right
after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots
what would you do if there was a trump
supporter right in front of you crying
in pain because they have to live under
communist tyranny
you know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
thanks for sticking with us
what a great interview
um i was excited about having matt on
because he does know so much
about the safety of weapons and what you
have to do to keep safe with weapons
because he has so much experience with
it um gabe i think that's something
missing sometimes in this conversation
is that there is a way to do this right
there is a way there is a way to keep
keep the center for me safe ourselves
safe our families safe or community safe
um and it's not going to be perfect like
we said on the firing range even
sometimes i'm sure they have incidents
even even as safe as safe as they're
trying to be and as much attention as
they're trying to pay paid to their
certification and what they're doing
with these weapons right um
so it's not going to be perfect right
but god damn we can try something to
make sure our children aren't
slaughtered in schools and i don't think
the idea that
we're just going to ban back doors in
porn
and give every teacher a gun is the idea
of keeping these kids safe this is
[ __ ] ridiculous well i mean it
becomes
something that is already you know they
are
they are
losing um
republicans right now i believe are
losing the
argument or the position that they're
trying to have because what they're
doing
is they will avoid anything under the
sun you know or they will blame anything
under the sun rather to avoid blaming
the gun
being the problem right which we know at
the end of the day it's the gun it's not
the you know the person behind the gun
no it's the gun the fact that we've got
you know 393 to 400 million guns that
are on
uh u.s soil owned by u.s citizens
which greatly outnumbers the 331 million
people that we have in this country is
insane right we we look at this and we
say oh it's backdoors or it's porn or
it's family values or reefer reaper
madness it's reefer madness it's pot
psychosis it's a broken home it's absent
fathers it's
family morals like whatever it is right
you've got them pushing
to get you outside of the idea that it's
the gun it was it's not the gun guys
listen i know the bullet
the the bullet that killed the person
came out of the gun and was fired from
the tree like it
they will do whatever they can
to blame
anything else right they'll be like well
the weather that day the weather that
they was stormy and stormy weather has
uh the ability to change someone's mood
emotional state so really we should be
banning
rain and clouds like they're already
going against climate change so it's
like it would make time as well you
might as well ban
ban the storms that way um you know
that way
that way you have the ability to go
outside after you're not watching porn
anymore like we joke about it now
but i guarantee someone
someone out there is going to use their
microphone to say
well the weather in texas that day right
was this and there were more electrical
particles in the air some [ __ ] some
q and on [ __ ] speaking of q anon
nonsense
this [ __ ] [ __ ] i can't believe we
still have to listen to her and heard
nonsense but we do because folks we
can't look away this is literally
laura ingraham's argument
for
mass shootings and children being killed
is marijuana
is the reason why
that this is happening let's listen to
this stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] because i'm
telling you
people that you know people that you
talk to they're gonna start saying this
dumb [ __ ] because she's [ __ ] puking
it out of her [ __ ] let's listen it
was initially reported that he was a
user in fact he got angry that his
grandmother and his mother didn't want
him to use marijuana
but again we don't know more it was just
mysteriously taken out of an article in
the new york times
but why aren't people in general not
talking more about the pot psychosis
violent behavior uh connection
well that's a very good question no no
it's not a good question yeah it's not a
good question that's not a problem this
isn't a thing it does not cause violence
it doesn't yeah it's like that scene
from i think it was harold and kumar go
to white castle where they play that
fake commercial where the guy's like oh
man i'm so high and he like pulls out
his dad's shotgun and that's the like
psa for not smoking marijuana right
right
that's the same thing right they're
going to keep pushing i you know i said
it last time i was like here comes the
reefer madness and then today it's just
completely trendy for madness forever
we're going to keep pushing it as far as
they can
to say he was a user i have never ever
been called a user well you know what
anyone i know even people who have
like pot farms
do not ever say
i'm a user like no one ever calls
himself a user like a user is typically
used for something that is like oh
that's a very addicting drug and that
does have detrimental side effects to
your health and well-being
no one ever says oh yeah
he's a user that's something you said in
like the 1950s when reefer madison
around he's like oh that jimmy that
jimmy hooligan kid he's a
he's a user he's a user of the marijuana
it's like for no no
[ __ ] well so here's the problem is she
says he's a user
and i believe he is a user gabe he was a
user of assault style weapons that he
was not trained to use right that's the
user problem that he had the problem is
that he was able to go into a store with
a [ __ ] credit card and get these guns
for free and go use them you [ __ ]
bonehead laura ingram he is a user
and it wasn't the marijuana that he was
killing these children with you dumb
[ __ ] this is an absolute
nonsense the the other thing is this jd
vance porn thing what in the actual [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] i i don't know what is this
[ __ ]
before we go into jd vance though i just
realized and i don't know if anyone has
thought about this but
the same way so if anyone actually has
gone out there and purchases like
marijuana cannabis any of those products
you know uh within that family and from
a dispensary you mean if you're a user
if you're a user and you go buy cannabis
um you can't use your credit card whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second
wait a second
just wait a second just follow me just
follow me for a second i know it's gonna
sound crazy it's gonna sound crazy
but
the the cannabis industry
you cannot purchase
from a dispensary
or other places with a credit card the
reason is the banking institutions have
decided that it would be used for drugs
right so they have canceled any method
of pain so that's why when you go in it
is a completely for cash
uh
concept right they have to literally
bring out private security in like
colorado and other places to transport
the cash because that's all they have
access to that they get it's cash for
pot right cash for cannabis is what it
is and so
these credit card companies decided
through you know lobbying in other
places that we will not allow
you to actually use credit cards to
purchase
so why don't we and this sounds pretty
crazy but why don't we apply the same
concept
to guns
you cannot purchase guns with a credit
card
if you purchased a gun with a credit
card and that gun
was used to kill people
i think there should be multiple people
that are responsible
so if you don't want that liability on
your hands then as a credit card company
you should say no dude i don't want any
of this [ __ ] nope do not want any of
this if you do it you buy with cash and
that's your [ __ ]
but i don't want to have to be the one
that is attached
to this gun that killed a person or
killed children
so i think that credit cards should
should go to a cash only system right
especially these people were like i
don't want the government regulating
this well then you probably are also the
person that's like well i don't want
this uh under my record i don't want
this logged then go then go off the
radar like go off the grid put cash down
on the table if you want you user you
user
listen listen there is so many things
little bitty things that people wouldn't
even notice that we could do
that would prevent
people getting these weapons
so [ __ ] quickly
in a heated moment where they if they
have
a derangement because that's the other
thing i want to blame it on is mental
illness like ah that's cool that's cool
you want to blame it on mental illness
i'll stand around and wait for you to
[ __ ] do something about it though i
mean this is this this idea that it's
referred that it's backdoors that it's
porn this [ __ ] porn thing
really [ __ ] really
honestly
what do you think
someone who watches porn why why what
the [ __ ] does that have to do
i just i can't even [ __ ] figure it
out yeah what jd what kind of porn is jd
vance watching
i ca i can't understand it like what
kind of power i don't know here's the
thing what kind of weed is laura ingram
smoking i think [ __ ] are you people on i
think just like uh nick fuentes i think
jd vance might be watching some
some kinky stuff you know no judgement
you do what you want to do
it could be you know it's like you know
bj's on guns or i don't know whatever
this sounds like this sounds like a new
hot uh tab on board maybe i don't know
it could be
i don't know
i wouldn't know i'm not really into that
type of uh 2a porn
but
don't be surprised if that already
existed hey man 2a porn we're on to
something here yeah we better uh we
better start trademarking this before uh
pornhub hops onto this
especially if jd vance decides to point
out that he's on the 2a porn train
this is really dumb
does anyone really buy this [ __ ] or do
they just spew it back out into the
[ __ ] ethos i don't know i think there
are some people porn and weaver are the
problem i think some people really do
believe it they really do believe the
fact that these are the problems they
are the crux of the problem not the fact
that they've got you know multiple
firearms like you see the photos out
there of people who are proud gun owners
and it's like i stopped i stopped
counting when i hit 30 guns in that room
or when i hit 50 guns on that deck right
like you look at these look at these oh
you're talking about the pictures where
they got them all sprawled right when
they lay them out they took the time to
lay them out so nicely you know and i
look at that i'm like one you have way
too much time in your hand two
you could have used that money for other
things like how many times you're gonna
go out and have
multiple guns in each finger trying to
like is that what you're trying to do
yeah but gabe see when you're a user
like that you would be proud of your
your usage so you should lay out all
your empty packs
of of of herb
and lay them out and take pictures of it
i should yeah i should be actually my
husband you're a proud you're a proud
user
you're proud users you're a bad user
listen speaking of proud um proud boys
is our title today because something
happened
where they're crying and crying more
um
and i want to get to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends so let's do that
right now let's surf the tweety tweets
and trendy trends
starting with the proud boys let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we have reached the
shitless roundup where we round up all
the tweety tweets and trendy trends and
and this month is pride month
even though we're talking about the
proud boys do you think they really
thought about that name before they
picked it out like
i don't think they did but i do remember
i think it was in 2020 uh or maybe 2021
but i believe it was 2020 um
and you you will see it
this month especially
reclaiming
or taking over the proud boy hashtag uh
was one of the most wonderful things to
witness on twitter you had these idiots
these bigots these people who are
[ __ ] 2a porn
you know [ __ ] jd
right reaper addicts right they're like
yeah they're like we're going here and
we're gonna have this rally we're doing
this hashtag proud boy hashtag proud boy
hashtag proud boy
and i gotta tell you the people that
came in and took over the hashtag
proudboy during pride month and i think
it might have been also in another time
too but it was incredibly effective and
wonderful to watch just was this where
was this where a bunch of really
good-looking dudes um would post
half-naked pictures and tag it with yeah
get up in their timeline yeah get up in
their time yeah the crowd the crowd the
hashtag i mean here's the thing they
their logo is a [ __ ]
wait wait who's the proud boys what what
yeah
no it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait stop stop hold up wait a
minute
you're telling me because i i i not i i
have not done this much research into
this you're telling me not only did they
call themselves the proud boys
their their logo is is designed after a
penis is that what you're saying it's
not after a penis it's a [ __ ] rooster
or whatever but oh a kite
is
i thought i thought you meant they love
[ __ ] i mean not well i don't know maybe
no judgment they could i'm not sure but
there's there's no reason there's no
reason to believe that some of them
might they don't they do wear kilts and
then they they they've they've moved
they've shown their bare ass to people
and because that's what a manly man does
i thought
i thought you meant i thought you meant
they were walking around with penises
all over them and no who knows i mean i
mean i'm not against it i think i think
that would actually be funnier than the
[ __ ] chicken right but they have this
[ __ ] rooster
as their logo right so that's why i say
[ __ ]
oh my god everyone do you think they
thought do you think they thought that
through when they were like let's name
ourselves brown boys and they're like
what
what mascot can we have that represents
us as proud boys manly men who who
absolutely are [ __ ] white
nationalists who hate right yeah they're
like
they're like what is more american
and uh they go
well
farms farms are pretty american that's
pretty manly and they're like well
what's the thing that gets you up in the
morning and they're like you know
someone people like oh a little pill you
know somebody i'll be like oh it's a
rooster a [ __ ] rooster and then they
were like and then they're like oh yeah
yeah that's a good [ __ ] you know
right you know the other thing too is it
could be uh
confused that they're chickens
they're a bunch of chicken [ __ ] that
could be yeah you could say they're
chickens too somebody somebody brought
up in the chat that uh i meant chaps no
i did mean i did mean kills they were
yeah they yeah they were kids and they
also they wrote them they wrote on their
asses too i think exactly on their and
any on each ass cheek they wrote a
message on there i don't remember proud
boy or whatever it said it was dumb but
you know again macho men two-way rain
you know porn [ __ ] right i you know i
you know what pisses me off about the
proud boy thing because we're joking
about it but what pisses me off
is um the leader gavin what the hell was
his name yeah gavin mcginnis gavin
mcguinness the guy who found it didn't
he didn't he like
do something with the dildo to prove
that he's not gay or some [ __ ] yes on on
air which i will not bring up the clip
and show on here because i'm sure we'll
get flat for it right yeah
youtube that at all to prove that gavin
mcginnis was not gay
he shoved a dildo into his ass on
television live streamed it well you
live streamed it yeah okay what this is
what pisses me off about that kind of
[ __ ] is that these people believe that
it's the it's somehow like the physical
sex and that's where they get this they
they start these tropes with
with the lgbtq people that they're
predators and [ __ ] because they think
it's like it's not always about the
physical sex you [ __ ] idiot like they
love a person yeah they have feelings
for a person they have attraction to a
certain person and a certain gender
they really
because they're so frightened of their
own insecurities that they don't
understand that and it really it really
pisses me off that they it almost feels
like to me you know we joke about it but
it almost feels like to me they were
trying to
uh steal away
um the the pride that someone would have
to
to to not be afraid
to express their sexuality express their
their identity right
the other thing too is that you know
he's using it as a gimmick as a way to
you know show like oh i'm not gay and he
does this thing that
kind of devalues right exactly people
who actually do that right for pleasure
or whatever you know well the other
thing so yeah the other thing too is
that they're devaluing they're devaluing
um an lgbtq person and dehumanizing them
as if as if the only thing
the only thing that a lgbtq uh person
does and their only part of their
identity is to stick a dildo in their
ass right this is i mean ridiculous and
it's like no pun intended but you know
he's attempting to make them the butt of
the joke here right like he is using a
dildo
in a negative way right where to be like
well i'm not gay because this anyone can
do it you know and it's like
why why did you try to co-opt and steal
that right like what does that what does
that prove
and what does that like how does that
make you seem any better in any way
right you just seem more insensitive
and not you know i'm an ally i don't
really consider that considering your
group's history
but to shove a dildo up your ass
livestream right
like that's that's [ __ ] weird man it
is weird weird that's [ __ ] and
whether it's projects we're not we are
definitely never going to on this show
we are never going to live stream
me or music
no it's doing
well i never say never i guess but
here's what i'll tell you i i am excited
that it is pride month um and and don't
let the proud boy steal this away even
though that name is now associated with
uh domestic terrorists and white
nationalists because we've seen over the
um over the weekend with the nra nazi
rally down in houston where they danced
on the graves of 19 children
um and they were excited oh they were
excited about back doors
and you know armed guards and arming
teachers i mean they you know
at that at that convention they named
everything you know we want to blame it
on the mentally ill and we want to put
them in mental institutions we want to
blame them on the back doors it was the
teachers it was this it was that you
know again they'll blame anything if
it's not the gun well right just the
same way donald trump will blame the
shirts that they're wearing because
that's really what he wants to ban this
video came out um that they wouldn't
sounds like censorship right well cancel
culture is what it is technically i mean
it really is it seems like disney style
[ __ ] disney style gazpacho um petri dish
type stuff um here in the in the uh the
hall where
um half the auditorium was full and they
wouldn't even let him more guests to get
it more full which is kind of odd to me
because they're wearing a certain type
of
shirt i guess maybe they had [ __ ] on
their shirt maybe that's what it was i
don't know but they also did not want
cueing on insignia either watch this
video these proud boys trying to beg to
get into this event listen to them cry
and cry and [ __ ] and moan these bunch
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
me right now that proud boys are not
allowed at this trump event i'm telling
you right now any sort of proud boys or
qan and cigna
yeah has to go all right
i'm gonna leave i'm gonna leave but we
can't just leave
well here's the thing if you listen to
the background do you hear who's
speaking in the background
is it trump it is trump trump's actually
on the speaker the loudspeaker in the
background and the reason why they're
kicking these guys out at this at this
point probably or not allowing the menu
because trump's in there and he does not
want he again i said earlier he wants
them to stand back and stand by he just
doesn't want them to stand just go
outside of the arena here right i don't
want you to stand stand back
way back and way by i don't want you to
stand anywhere close to me because it
looks a little weird when i'm probably
about to be charged with
insurrection here and you guys are the
help you tried to help me overthrow the
constitution that looks really weird
let's finish their crying here
we
why do i have to walk why do i have to
walk you just said you're going to leave
this direction sir that's why no i mean
like why why do proud boys have to watch
well it's because you can't have any
logos or insignia for this event so
again they're not
trump doesn't when the republicans don't
want to ban these type of people right
they're not like you're a [ __ ] box
you're a [ __ ] white nationalist
you're a domestic terrorist it's like we
don't want you to dress up as a domestic
terrorist look if you're going to come
in here wear a different costume than
your yeah just wear the red hat we'll
all know it's you right put on a trump
36 trump 2036 shirt right because i mean
that's
one you you hear this guy he's like
listen i'm gonna walk i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go okay then go you're not gonna
convince these police and the security
that all of a sudden they're like oh you
know what
we'll we'll let this slide we're going
to forget about this policy and he's
like well trump personally invited me
we're part of the vip right
and
any pers
and he told me he told me shut the [ __ ]
up man you said you're going to go
just be a guy just be a man just be a
man go take your [ __ ] 2a porn and get
out the door right and really honestly
what they're telling him is just change
go outside change your shirt she even
says she says turn your shirt inside out
right just change your shirt dummy
you're not understanding it's not you
right it's it's that they don't want to
be they don't want they don't want what
is the domestic terrorist costume inside
this event right we don't want to see
the [ __ ] on your shirt well the other
thing is the nra does not want to be
seen associated with this domestic
terrorism group and the reason why is
because of the shooting in buffalo that
is the reason why it tears apart their
narrative it tears it apart that the
people who are domestic terrorists are
the ones who don't want regulation and
there's a reason for it there's a reason
there is a reason and the nra does not
want to be associated with a bunch of
[ __ ] domestic terrorists i mean they
do right they just don't want to be
caught doing it exactly it's the same
thing when we saw let's go brandon
converted into nazi right propaganda you
only hear now a few people now and then
say let's go brandon i mean some guns
are branded with let's go brandon right
but you don't see many people that were
pushing the let's go brandon kind of
movement say let's go brandon anymore
that's because they're [ __ ] nazis
let's finish this nazi video
and the people who are crying
you're kidding me right because the
trump campaign gave us vip tickets you
can turn your shirt inside out or you
can purchase another shirt this is
really happening here yeah you can buy
it you can buy a trump shirt if you want
so can i ask why proud boys aren't
allowed here it's the logo it's the
shirt and i don't make the videos
but we're giving you some options
is there is there a reason why proud
boys aren't allowed here
they made the rules man that's all
that's all i could say but the the
actual campaign themselves
so why is it
why can't
this is the same dumb mother jesus
christ he literally said that he's like
dude we're just repeating ourselves
right now like i
watching this i'm just like the proud
boys have a very low level of
comprehension well they are dumb [ __ ]
yeah
literally like look just you just got to
change a shirt you could buy a shirt you
can flip the shirt inside out like
do something
other than wear the shirt as it is right
now
if you want to know what the [ __ ] has
been yeah exactly if you want to go in
and use your vip ticket that the trump
campaign gave you then just turn the
shirt inside out you got you got a
little yellow logo with with pb on there
turn the [ __ ] polo inside out and
then no one will i mean we'll all know
but no one's going to bother you about
it right that's the point of this i'm
going to go i'm going to go i'm going to
go because the point is the nra doesn't
want any pictures of domestic terrorists
inside their event that's what they
don't want that's why they don't want
them to wear the insignia they don't
want domestic terrorists dressed up in
domestic terrorist costumes inside their
event because they don't want pictures
taken that the proud boys are there and
they're supporting domestic terrorists
because they are domestic terrorists
the funniest part is
the other video is when they did make
their way outside or sometime when
they're outside there was tens of them
gabe tens of them really scary oh man
only two hands
yeah
and what's funny is that you gotta hear
what they were yelling at the protesters
they're like the protesters are here
because they don't have job or some you
just watch it
here we are today
get a job so they they sling around the
f word here's the proud boys slinging
around the the slang with the f word um
and then they're then they're accusing
the people who are at the protest
they're protesting the protest and i'm
not having that's the proof because they
are protesting and they're able to
protest yeah that's their proof that
they don't have a job which is very
confusing i'm also look i'm gonna make a
wild assumption here right now these
guys who don't have jobs these proud
boys that are clearly so proud they're
covering their faces right now right
that they are at this protest because
they don't have jobs but they're also on
unemployment which means they're relying
on the government like lazy people
to be my guess is there's you know they
accused they're always up in our
comments you're paid by sorrows and
you're paid by this dark i wish
i wonder i wonder who these guys these
proud boys here
um oh boy
boy boy whoo baby i'm just saying this
is the uh supreme race
boy he's had a lot of supreme tacos for
sure
tacos get there i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna be right there
these are the same [ __ ] these
proud boys these people bitching about
not being able to wear a shirt inside of
a private event number one they're the
[ __ ] that are absolutely all
the time
all the time bitching about cancel
culture but they're also the ones that
were like you you can't you can't force
me to wear a mask inside a private
business you can't do that and here they
are they're like yeah we can yeah that's
a thing it's a private space
and you have to wear a mask so you don't
get people sick just like it's a private
space you can't wear parabola insignia
because we don't want the nra
associating with what looks like uh
domestic terror especially domestic
terrorist and domestic terrorist
costumes we definitely
don't want that jesus [ __ ] christ
this this this stupidity of this q anon
proud boys devil never end of course
we're going to get more and more news in
this in june
right when we when we actually go
through these public hearings which we
are going to uh stream the live uh
public hearings here on the tony
michaels podcast as they happen um there
are some more trending topics chuck
grassley is trending do you guys you
guys know why trek grassley is he's
still alive
well maybe that's why he's trending is
he's still alive people are like no no
he really is he's he really is still
alive like are you kidding me are you
sure
are you sure someone's going to check on
him can we get a quick pulse check right
he put a meter by his face to see the
breathing i don't i don't know why he's
trending here he's um
he didn't expect pence to preside this
seems like um it has to do with january
6
because we know that uh chuck grassley
would have been the presiding officer on
january's
on um
january 6th if
mike pence decided to bow out right so
right right this is this is the big
argument um you could say bow wow or you
could say maybe leave trump hanging yeah
oh that's a wow um
hey look look i i didn't say it right
trump's followers did right so here's
here's the thing is on january 6 uh
donald trump wanted mike pence to make
him dictator which is not a thing right
so when they certify the results from
the state they're already certified
results yeah the states have already
certified him which is the
constitutional duty
of the states which makes
whoever is certified the president of
the united states yeah the only thing is
after the civil war they wanted a way
for the states to argue this point right
because the confederate states wanted to
rejoin but they wanted a way to [ __ ]
and moan about the who the president was
right and they wanted this ability for
congress to have this show where they
[ __ ] and moan like the brow boys were
at the nra event so it's congress's
opportunity to stage
theater
and that's all it really is because
really what mike pence or any vice
president is doing
is just reading the envelope like at the
oscars it's already been voted on that
person's already essentially won the
oscar this is just the celebration
ceremony where they call the name and
hand them the award right
that's kind of what this is um which is
really [ __ ] dumb to think that the
vice president can overturn this because
really if that was the case joe biden
should have just declared hillary
clinton clinton king in 2017 right
exactly the 2016 election i mean that's
the case why the [ __ ] didn't we just do
that right and whatever happens in the
next election well right joe biden is
such an authoritarian and he's in his
design is to take over the country and
be the dictator or whatever the [ __ ]
they think he is why the [ __ ] wouldn't
he had just done that in 2017 right this
is really [ __ ] stupid like democrats
they [ __ ] suck at it they really
[ __ ] suck at it and also it's like
what wouldn't stop you know
biden or harris from doing the same in
2024 you know right well if you guys are
going to create this as a precedent then
right get ready for the thing going the
opposite way that you want also you can
even go back to the year 2000 where al
gore actually had to hand the presidency
to the other guy other than him
right
so it seems like um the questioning here
the line of questioning with chuck
grassley
um was that pence
would recuse himself
of the actual count allowing the senior
senator which would be chuck grassley to
take the gavel
at the at the um
at the actual um
where they certified the vote in
congress right and the the duty that
mike pence acts his constitutional duty
that he had to preside over that hearing
but the thing is is it's not really his
constitutional duty it's just someone's
right so if he would refuse to do it
then chuck grassley if chuck grassy
refused to do it then he would have
stepped up or someone else
you know in the line of secession would
have been the presiding officer
over that oscar over opening the
envelope and declaring who is red on the
envelope because that's truly what it
was
is the certified results were already
certified by the states it's in the box
and we're talking about to states rights
people here right these people on state
stretch state tracks state rights the
states the states right to certified it
already happened that was already a
thing this is all just a ceremony and
you people thought it was some sort of
uh opportunity to take over the
government and overturn the constitution
and that's where a lot of them are
getting into trouble and it seems like
chuck grassley is being questioned on
this
on this point um
i actually have a pretty good video on
this a walking video but i'm not going
to play it today but it seems to be some
other things trending here
um we
have um a hurricane season coming
um
right that's coming in yeah um it seems
like um we're gonna brace for a very uh
brutal hurricane season um for the
people out there in
the area where hurricanes affect not
just in our country but in other
territories and other countries out
there
that are affected by hurricanes but also
the other reason why i think hurricane
is trending is because everyone is um
yelling and screaming about some of the
some of the economy um
jamie dimon actually said a hurricane is
coming for the economy to brace yourself
and of course a lot of moglodites are
jumping onto this now i said this before
right inflation affects all americans
whether it's good or it's bad a lot of
americans
are helped by inflation believe it or
not i know it sounds contradictory but
it's because we have a heated economy
the reason why we have over inflation
there's a lot of different reasons why
and the other thing they're talking
about is janet yelling saying she
underestimated the amount of inflation
and how long it would last i think
everyone has underestimated how long
inflation would last because i think the
idea that the demand would keep this
long because the reason why we have
inflation is because we have demand the
opposite of inflation folks for the
economy is a recession and that is
literally what the fed is going to try
to do is to draw us into
a slow
recession
they want to recess the economy and draw
down and stop inflation by raising
interest rates now here's the thing
rather you're an inflation type
recession or an economy or a recessed
economy
the rich benefit
from both
right right the rich are not not excited
about high interest rates they would
much rather live in this inflated
economy you would much rather live in
this inflated economy so it is really
[ __ ]
it is really [ __ ] weird this
dichotomy that we have in this country
not understanding
what inflation and what recession is now
there are arguments to be made that we
need inflation protection like we had in
the year 2021 in the form of the child
tax credit that was inflation
protection but here we are because we
have
republican senators that would not vote
uh to extend the child tax credit that
inflation protection we do not have it
in this year but we still have the
demand
you see
see the reason why janet yellen
surmised that inflation wouldn't last as
long as because the inflation protection
was going away they thought the demand
would subside but it hasn't and the
reason why it hasn't is because people
are we're basically at full employment
in this country now the sucky part is is
even at full employment people aren't
reaching the amount of income that it
takes to make a living wage
and that's why when you go to some of
these minimum wage jobs there are no
workers
because they can go travel and sell
their labor somewhere else that is a
less stressful job for a lot more pay
for their labor they can trade it
differently we live in a capitalist
society
as much as these self-proclaimed free
capitalists don't understand capitalism
it is an infuriating and infuriating
this morning that that these
self-acclaimed free market capitalists
are taking the words of jamie dimon what
he's saying and janet yelling and not
understanding that the argument that
they're making is against
against a good economy like we have the
keys
right now in our economy
if we just actually elected people who
gave a [ __ ] about us who gave a [ __ ]
about us
just like joe biden gives a [ __ ] about
those amazon workers who want to
unionize right the point is the point is
is that the economy is roaring the
economy is hot the economy is inflating
meaning it's growing it's not recessing
it's not shrinking so
but
more
more people need more piece of that pie
is what we need to have
so what is going to happen with this fed
and i i'm predicting this to happen just
like elon musk will never own twitter
here's what i predict happens gabe i
predict that the fed is going to raise
the interest rate they are going to
slowly draw us into a recession um the
administration this will probably be
sometime into the next year the
administration will absolutely deny that
it's a recession um and if they do admit
that it's a recession they'll say well
we had to recess the economy to stop
inflation um you know they're going to
do this this dance
that is um but what you can do out there
if you are out there and you're
listening like well what the hell can i
do
because you can't you know you can't
convince rich folks you're not in charge
of the fed right um you don't have a
direct line into joe biden's telephone i
don't think
maybe you do maybe you don't but what
you can do
is to
is to find level-headed people who can
set policy that is better for the people
who need a bigger piece of the pie
right who are who are on board for a
bigger piece of the pie but not so much
that they would be an all or nothing
crowd because we have a lot of that gabe
i've seen a lot of that going around
social media here the last few days
about student debt they all are nothing
crowd hey if we can't get everything we
want then we want nothing and let the
republicans run it
i don't know about you
but i definitely don't want someone
who can't even figure out
he can't even figure out that they can't
bomb mexico and can't bomb hurricanes
right i think reefer madness and porn is
our gun problem in this country i do not
want those people in charge of the
economy yeah and it's not the
[ __ ] that i want in charge of
the economy i they don't even understand
porn they don't even understand
reefer how marijuana works
and guns you really want them to run
your economy that's what you want get
the [ __ ] out of here with this all or
nothing [ __ ]
joe biden is not your enemy folks he's
not now is joe biden going to get
everything done that he wants to get
done i don't believe so no i don't think
we'll get to the amount of level because
we we the people have not given him the
government yet that he needs to get some
of these things done
and we have to do that in this midterm
we have to make sure that the guy wants
to ban backdoor porn in ohio does not
get seated in the united states senate
this is very [ __ ] important folks
the dude who is on the republican ticket
in ohio
wants to ban porn to stop gun violence
that is his solution
the guy the guy who is trying to take
away warnock's seat in georgia
claims he loves god and he's such a
godly person
but there's all kinds of [ __ ] especially
about guns in hershel walker's closet
dude [ __ ] doesn't even live in
georgia right
so that's the guy that you want to have
control
over your economy who want you want him
to make votes based on to help you with
your economy that's the guy this is also
the same guy who defrauded uh uh
investors who lied about his business
who took a ppp loan
like
herschel walker you know right is the is
the face of the republican party the man
who cannot
make any sense of what he says he's
talking about men watching women
uh
it's a program
for the government you know it's
it doesn't make any sense he's also the
man that he does not believe in
evolution right
he is the man
that is a walking
uh case study well he's ran he's ran in
his life before he's he's running
physically run right however
when it comes to politics
you know he's not one for showing up and
actually delivering and you can see that
when he just ghosted the debates because
he in his mind which kind of a smart
move for him was if i don't say [ __ ]
in the debate
they can't oh yeah they can't hold it
against me you know speaking of holding
things against people did you see the
tweet from marsha blackburn
did you see this tweet yesterday mercer
blackburn marshall say my [ __ ] my [ __ ]
marcia she she really she really is
behind the ball here like
several several years behind the ball um
here is a picture of this tweet
wait you're telling me the woman
investigate hillary clinton
this is i'm not [ __ ] you gabe this
is five thirty one twenty two is this
because of the clinton lawyer that got
off so as everyone knows the news is
that michael sussman uh the former
attorney of the clinton campaign who
went to the fbi to report crimes by the
way
like that was the whole intent but he
had to he had to withhold some
information because of uh
attorney-client privilege and some
how that stuff works and i'm not a
lawyer i know that some of that works
yeah but clearly in this trial it did
not take the jury very long to
understand that this guy did not lie to
the fbi right this guy did not lie to
the fbi that's all a bunch of [ __ ] and
really honestly
they thought this was gonna be a gotcha
moment and they were gonna lock him away
and all this [ __ ] and hillary was gonna
be the the russian colluder and all this
like the only thing that the pr trial
proved the only thing that the trial
proved is not only was hillary clinton
her campaign not colluding with russia
but the other campaign was doing the
exact thing
like
that's
we had a troll we had a troll in the
comments last i think it was last week
when we were yeah it might have been
last week or the week before that i
forget uh but basically this person and
i intentionally ignored it for that
reason he kept he's like just wait till
the suspense trial comes out you're
going to find out that clue do this and
do this i saw
the comments kept coming from this one
person and i was like i'm not going to
acknowledge this i'm not going to give
it the time because it's a complete bs
case that's going to be thrown out and
it's another one of those
trump is gonna be reinstated on march
13th 2021 you know it's it's q a non
nonsense it is just absolute [ __ ]
garbage and and it really is it really
is cute that we have to continue to do
this [ __ ] from like these proud boy
types i tweeted i think i tweeted um
breaking the hunter biden's laptop to
release a statement on the emails of
michael sussman or michael sussman's
emails like literally that michael
sussman stuff is the same [ __ ] as the
hunter biden's laptop like really
honestly if we ever get an answer of
what and where and how much this laptop
does not [ __ ] matter this laptop has
touched so many hands
so many
i don't know you know sticky hands no
that doesn't make any better this laptop
has been touched by so many
hands right uh
that people like matt gates has a copy
of it now whether
what matt gates has submitted in the
thumb drive was
hunter biden's laptop or maybe
it was actually his own laptop well that
could be you know you know it it really
does i really start the question like
did they think you know there's nothing
on this laptop besides him getting
hookers and blow which everyone knows
that hunter biden like hookers and blow
it's not a secret it's not a [ __ ]
secret and he was taking pictures of
himself with hookers and blow which
some of them might be crimes in some
places but he's not the president he's
not in the white house he's not an
advisor that's not a thing that happens
he's not making millions if not billions
of dollars right a personal relationship
established by your father who was the
president aka
donald trump right right this is all
projection but the beautiful part about
this hundred bucks laptop thing is they
literally have created
created hunter biden's laptop just like
they created this 2000 mule [ __ ] and
this corruption goes deep it was
actually um
her name is um
i think her name is burke um she's a
city council person in virginia did you
see this video yesterday she has had
about enough of the corruption right and
the [ __ ] have you watched this video
i want to leave on this video this is
[ __ ] fantastic i love her watching
the full thing i think i watched like
halfway through and then so this is her
talking about um a city manager that
they want to fire and i think they want
to fire because um they tried to bribe
her or something this seems like what
she's saying let's let's watch this
video she's been a great city manager
i'm not going to put her down but you
sat here and you lied in my face you
lied in my faith so so i want to i'm
gonna point out she really has the
[ __ ] energy really yeah yeah yeah and
i think yeah
she's well listen to what she says here
the battle and i want you to lie to
these people to say that you didn't say
that
you said that this woman has done her
job and she has been nothing but great
to this community which we know we know
she has done a job we know she has bent
over backward we know she has looked the
side to some of the votes that you have
tried to have people pay you all to
provoke that she looked aside that she
could have reported
she got a lot on this council and that's
why they want to get rid of her damn and
i hope that y'all feeling what's
happening and i hope you make your
decision when when november comes
because
that's the [ __ ]
i'm mad as a [ __ ]
i am should not know what's been going
on i know somebody came to my office and
asked me to deal with this stuff because
they've been asked to be paid let's take
a look
i'm going to research this meeting right
now i'm going to get really successful
she
you know someone actually did what the
internet is supposed to do
and they made a nice little video and i
want to i want to exit and she she
responded to it right well i think so
and you can go go follow her um she goes
she's like who did this
right yeah well no no this is someone
else who who who posted this
on who did this but this is this is what
the internet is very good at so i want
to leave you with what the internet
actually is supposed to do with these
type of situations
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
i
am i am
[Music]
oh my god
that is that is internet gold right
there that is what the internet is
supposed to do for us that is how it's
supposed to work folks speaking of the
internet speaking of the internet every
single weekday monday through friday we
are on the interwebs
uh youtube twitter twitch two hours
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central and we also simulcast from the
minus touch facebook page
until tomorrow i don't have anything
better than that gabe i really don't i
couldn't i couldn't even follow her i
couldn't even follow her gabe gotta go
speaking of that i did follow her on
facebook go her handle is on that as on
the original clip go to my my timeline
and find and follow her
i hope she keeps this up and keeps being
loud about these issues and i hope the
internet keeps producing
fantastic videos just like they did
there until tomorrow folks noon eastern
eleven central youtube twitter twitch
and the minus facebook page
we will see you surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking